Let's get started.
Okay, if you haven't been with us for a while,
know that you can do cheek swabs.
We do one-on-one calls again.
So you'll see that on the homepage of the member site.
So that's why the homepage of the member site is so crucial
for you to go to so that you can see any announcements.
So make sure you do that.
And look at that.
You just got to fill out the form.
If you want to one-on-one call yet to fill out the form.
On the homepage of the member site.
I'm sorry.
Fill out the form for the one-on-one because you have to agree
to the agreements.
Also, I want to clarify about the cheek swab tested.
So this is the agreements you just have to fill out that form.
The agreements that you have made it anything else.
You can pay for it at the time to legally.
It's not a telemedicine.
It's not legally safe.
So I'll know that.
Also, no, I do want to clarify somebody asked a question
that when I sent them their cheek swab results back,
they basically sent this all again,
because I wanted a full report on everything.
I can't do that anymore.
I'm going to get a full report.
You're just going to get changes.
I'm going to say here's what I found in your cheek swab testing today.
Anybody who's done it in the last three weeks knows.
And here's the changes.
Change this.
Here's where's changes.
And if there's a right change,
I usually tell them that I'm going to be sending you a flash drive
with the right program.
You're not going to get a full report.
I mean, first of all,
there's just not enough time to give you a full report.
You know, I'm not going to sit there and type on the entire report
of everything that I tested.
I'm just giving you the changes.
I'm trying to keep this to 15 minutes for you.
And I'll tell you everybody,
it's both way over 50 minutes,
but I'm not charging you anymore for that.
So I'm trying to keep your expenses down.
I just don't have time to type out,
dictate out a full report for somebody on every single thing that I tested.
So that's just not happening.
I understand.
Some people want more than that.
So that's not what you're happy with receiving them.
Then,
then,
then please don't request it.
She's what we don't need to be worried about.
So that's,
I can only do what I can do.
So just know that.
It's just one person that had a comment.
Whoever all the courses are free to you.
And remember to search the blog for different things.
Let's jump to the questions.
Just curious to treat my congestion.
I put VIX.
Boy, that brings back memories.
My mom used VIX on everything.
Right.
Well,
cheer off or everything was a VIX.
I used VIX for my.
For my to inhale with steam of water,
if that was kind of stupid,
because all the extra ingredients with VIX.
Besides the men fall on campus.
And you,
you can live this.
I would say it's stupid.
Yeah, there's control even there.
There's serpentine.
There's, you know,
there's different stuff in it.
It's probably not the best for us.
There is a natural VIX.
On the market.
It's not called VIX.
But it's called.
It's a natural.
Waitement.
That doesn't have those things in it.
That we've used on our kids.
And you can use probably a better thing is just to use a central oils.
You can use essential oils.
You just invent on.
That is a good,
a better thing to use.
So.
What are your thoughts on a leotro?
That be a good thing to add for breast cancer would be best to add the apricot seed form or the supplement form.
So yes.
I'm big fan of leotro.
So you could get the seed form that this is the seed.
And people can just eat these seeds.
They look like almonds.
They taste like poison.
So.
I'm not a fan of these things.
I could just about eat anything, but these days horrible.
So.
And I'm not so sure how good it is for your kids.
So we have these on sale in the store because some people like,
no, I've used to them.
I really like them.
And so we do have these at our store.
Typically, if we test to cheek swab test and we test,
we find that B17 slash a big deal in the slash leotro is good for somebody that we use the capsule for.
This is the capsule form that is just the B17 component.
It's not the entire seed.
And it comes in 500 milligram or 100 milligram capsules.
And if depending on what I recommended for you, make sure you purchase the right thing.
500 milligram capsules is five times the 100 milligram capsules.
And you don't want to be taking too much of something.
If that's what you're doing.
So just make sure you're aware of that.
We have a big grab letters on the store.
So it should make that stink.
But if you're just like, you know, and it's never been tested for me,
I just feel like I want to take it.
You can take this thing, this product right here.
This product is the is the entire seed itself that's just ground and encapsulated.
So it only has 60 milligrams of the B17 in it.
But from a whole food perspective, it can be better in ways.
It has the B15 that's also included in the apricot seed itself.
So you're just like, hey, I just want to start taking it.
I feel like to take that.
Then maybe you consider this.
We have all these in the store.
This would be more of a whole food type product.
You like trying to get 500 milligrams of B17 in you.
It's really hard to do that.
You're taking a lot of pills of this.
So it's better to take just one of the 500 milligrams.
So some people are taking three of the 500 milligrams.
You're taking 1500 milligrams.
Good as sex would be taking a ton of these.
And that would get costly for that.
So those are your choices for B17.
I recently had my vitamin D level tested.
It is 120 on my blood test, which is high.
Is there any concern about this level?
I had cancer many years ago.
This person's.
Husband cast cancer.
I was previously taken four of the 80 K.
Complete.
Reduced it to one few weeks ago because we're a vacation.
In a robot.
Oh, you know, I made a mistake.
You know, if you guys go to a robot, you have to bring me with.
You know, it's just for safety reasons.
So I forgot to tell you that.
That sounds like a good idea.
Sorry.
Okay.
480 K.
Avail is 20,000.
I use.
Deep.
So it's 5,000.
I use.
Vitamin D at each 80 K.
I typically recommend you take it one.
So.
But that being said, having a vitamin D level of 120.
Yeah, that's high by medical standards.
I think it's.
Trends in the lab.
Some labs.
30 to 80 is within normal wage.
It's 30 to 100.
I want.
You know, anybody.
I think it's better for anybody with cancer to have.
Vitamin D level over 80.
And I don't concerned about.
The high point at that level, unless it's over 200.
Maybe over 150.
But somebody who doesn't have cancer, vitamin D levels of 120.
Is that too high?
Really.
But I don't think you need to be taking for.
80 Ks or.
20,000.
And I use.
I think going down to one.
A day is really probably the right thing to do.
I'd be at 5,000 a day, especially going into the summer.
That's what I would do.
I have a metastatic breast cancer.
Bets to the bones.
For the January.
February went off all my meds.
Talk to my functional medical doctor.
As she ordered an extra dial.
And it is 26.
Is this in range?
Would you consider this okay?
She thought it might be a bit high.
Yet she wants it possibly to add.
One, the three C from pure encapsulation.
So one three C is a.
Is a product like dim that will help decrease.
That estrogens.
I just started the astral clear.
It was so far as I.
So there's nothing wrong with.
You really can't take too much.
Dim.
You know, our robot clear is good.
Because it's got one three C and Dim and another thing in it.
But.
Let's take a step back on this level of 26 of astral dial.
So.
Hold up a.
This is a Dutch test.
Readout.
So.
It your ester dial levels really depend.
Your estrogen and progesterone testosterone levels.
Your horrible levels really dependent how you're measuring them.
So if the ester dial was measured on a urine.
Dutch test.
So a Dutch test is an acronym for a dried urine test.
Something for hormones.
And it uses a proprietary type of.
A measuring device that is.
Is that's what a Dutch test is.
Now there's multiple labs that have that type of equipment.
This is through precision.
Diagnostics.
This readout right here.
This is the Dutch test.
I recommend.
There's other doctors that will do a blood test for estrogens.
Or they'll do a.
A saliva test for estrogens.
I think those are not accurate.
So here's the ester dial.
So ester dial is E2.
Right here.
Now you see the normal for ester dial is 1.8 to 4.5.
So this I cannot believe that an ester dial of 26 was from a Dutch test.
It just does that does not make sense to me.
So this is your.
I love the Dutch test because it really gives a whole picture of all your.
Your horrible metabolites.
So metabolite is.
This product in this.
This molecule in your body breaks down to.
Molecule B breaks down to molecule C breaks down to molecule D.
And sometimes molecule B is the most active molecule and molecule C is.
A kind of a dangerous metabolite.
And if that's too high, it can cause damage to the body.
We're hoping that it breaks down the molecule D before causes any damage.
And so you measure these.
What are called metabolites.
This is very important with horrible metabolism.
So you look up in this quarter up here and you have your.
Progesterones.
So this person in this example, I just pulled this off the website.
So this is a dead patient here.
This person has very low progesterone.
See how normal is the star to the star there in a low range here.
They're low progesterone low progesterone.
Now progesterone will convert us into esterone.
It will robotize into esterone in a robotized into ester dial.
So a robotization.
We've talked about this a lot.
You guys.
Some women might be on an.
A robotace inhibitor.
A robotace is the name of an enzyme that is found in.
Fat cells of all of our fat cells in both males and females.
So males and females have an enzyme called a robotace in the fat cells.
And it breaks down excess hormones.
Into testosterone.
And estrogen and typically into bad estrogens, quote unquote.
So we don't want to end up with excess hormones in our fat cells.
Well, if you have excess hormones of any kind, you will push them to your fat cells if you don't.
If you don't get rid of them in the toilet and hormones are the number one things that are reabsorbed in the lower part of the colon.
So males and females can have excess estrogens and testosterone and progesteroles in their fat cells.
I'll guarantee you do.
And then they can break down and break down into testosterone and bad estrogens and that could cause issues.
So that's called the aromatization because it uses the enzyme aromatase to break down those excess hormones that are stored.
In fat cells. Now it'll break down into the estrogens. So these are the estrogens here.
And esterol is E1 and esterdiol is E2 and esterol is E3.
And it breaks down through these different and through these different genetic pathways.
These are cytochrome P450 pathways.
And it breaks down into 16 hydroxy esterol and then it breaks down into 4 hydroxy esterol.
And this is the one that can really cause damage to cells and can cause cancer.
So any of these, any of these estrogens in excess, any of these estrogens in excess, all of these right here, any of these in excess excess can attach to estrogen beta receptors on the cell membranes of cancer cells.
And it does that and the estrogen beta receptor is an apoptotic receptor. So it blocks apoptosis. So it blocks the death of that cell.
So that's the whole idea with estrogen positive and her two positive cancers and progesterone positive cancers too.
And it's any of these ex estrogens, if they're high, if this one is high, it could be a cause of cancer.
Okay, any of these are high, they can attach to the estrogen beta receptors and then be an issue with blocking apoptosis.
So the idea of taking an aromatase inhibitor is to get rid of these estrogens so you those won't attach to the estrogen beta receptors and block apoptosis.
That's the whole idea.
The same thing, the whole idea of taking, you know, astro clear and so poroside and I3C and dim are to do the same things to get rid of the bad estrogens so that these excess estrogens and to help bring balance to your body.
That's that's the whole idea of taking them. So an astro dial of 26 had to be a measured and I believe not on a Dutch test but on a blood test and really, I think you should get a Dutch test.
A Dutch test is a good test and you can just order it and you do it at home if you're a test, send it in, takes about 10 days to get it back and it gives you a nice results.
This person, this person, this example of here had cancer and be concerned, especially at any hormone driven cancer.
They have high esterones, high ester dials. You want these things weighed out here. You want this little arrow here, weighed out here, this weighed out here, this weighed out here, this, this is really bad and I think they use this as an example because this could be a cancer causing results here.
This should not be red, it should be green weighed out here. You want these weighed out here, as many of them as possible. Some of these methylated ones can be high. This is why CO of T defects with breast cancer patients can be a problem because it could increase the two methoxy esterones and this would be a perfect example.
This example, if this is a true example, unless they just change the numbers out here, but if this is a true example, this is quite possibly a person with a lot of CO of defects, CO and T defects.
I would suggest there's another role with taking more of the estrogen lowering products, but I would suggest you get a more proper test.
Hello, we are in Northeast Iowa, thinking of gardening. Yay. Yay. I'm all for gardening. So do you use any organic fertilizer on yours? We have it to the past, but wondering what you do as this is your passion also with harvesting do you can or freeze or what kind of storage do you use?
Come this summer, I will share more if you want to see more pictures of our garden because my wife and I are very habit gardeners and our garden is very pretty and it's so much fun.
So I just believe God put us put man in the garden in a garden for the beginning for a very specific reason that I just love gardening.
So do we use any organic fertilizer? Well, my wife bought, I bought this stuff for our fruit trees last year. I actually didn't put it on. I forgot to tell you get it on again, put it on this year. This is the doctor earth's
organic fertilizer. My wife got some other, I think it's the same brand for the, it's for vegetables and for flowers. She's huge into flowers to see her flower garden.
But there's other brands, brands of organic fertilizer. I don't think you have to worry so much about what you're putting on your flowers, but on your vegetables, we either don't use really much for
produced fertilizer. We do a lot of composting. We add a lot of compost to our soil. We
so that's really how we mainly fertilized. We used to have rabbits. We'd use that fertilizer to our soil.
We had horses, we'd put horse manure on our soil. We'd always be tilling in organic fertilizer on our soil.
As far as harvested, we do catting both hot water bath and pressure catting. We do freeze our vegetables. You know, there's argument you lose nutrients hot water bath aid or
pressure can aid your vegetables. You lose nutrients in the water. Yes, that's true. You will lose nutrients that way. You still will lose nutrients if you're freezing your vegetables.
We're actually really praying about getting a freeze dry or they're very expensive, but we literally have so many raspberries and strawberries and blackberries.
We just started growing blackberries and different fruit and vegetables. And our kids and grandkids love eating the freeze dried stuff that's produced out there. So we like to get that to store that too.
Okay, I got a pre-dubo scan in January. So we've been talking about this pre-dubo scan. You know, I haven't talked. I got my dad a couple years ago, and I was happy with the results of my pre-dubo scan. So I didn't really talk it up that much until somebody else brought it up in January.
So, and this person is sharing their experience, which they don't think is a very good experience.
Though the description range about it being stronger better than MRIs, I recently was talking with someone who had one this month and thought her technician said it is the same MRI image image as the Minneapolis clinic.
Well, I would question that I don't think it's the same image as that. Another piece to know is that they are information mighty needed all the detailed questions about ethnic origin of grandparents of details that they ask on the history.
One of the slides just was to sign off on let's give them permission to use the information info as they please.
And I think that might be just because they're still trying to gather research on their equipment. Most importantly, my scan did not indicate any lumps in my left armpit, which are very prominent.
So when I asked to question for clarification, they said, is it because they are live bill, rather than tumors that didn't show up. This is the person asked this question, very good question.
They did not respond except to say my report was updated. When I went in to look, they had added a sentence in the report with no accompanying picture or circle say that I have bulky asymmetric coalition left.
So I was actually accidentally had not with the most likely metastatic in ideology. So when I called them out on adding it without a picture or answering my question, they ignored me.
Not the professional trust for the action on several levels. Yeah, I don't know. I mean, it's a radiologist doing that in their human and they make mistakes.
You know, I can't say, you know, that this is just 100 times better. I just don't know. It's just that's the way it's, that's the way it is basically marketed. It's marketed as if the next X ray and MRI and CT scan and a pet scan got together had a baby.
They're putting up more and more clinics having these, you know, time will tell. So it's unfortunate that this that you did not get, you know, the data that you wanted and don't feel bad about that.
But you just got to try it. It's like any test. I said these 100 times. You don't just look at one test. You got to look at multiple tests and compare data.
I recently had a pet scan that showed an additional nodule on the left lower my thyroid were previously. I had the right only the doctor wanted to remove half my thyroid was on the right and I declined. And certainly he will now concert you want to remove the whole thyroid.
What could I do to shrink these nodules?
Well, again, you want to diagnose what they're from and if they're if they're cancerous or if they are from hypothyroidism or Hashimoto's.
So what will cause thyroid nodules? Well, decrease in iodine, you know, will cause thyroid nodules. It's your iodine levels testing Hashimoto's the number one cause of thyroid nodules Hashimoto's if you had it biopsy the other nodule biopsy it was cancerous that does not mean the other this new nodule is cancer.
So get it if you're going to get this biopsy that will tell you the answer to that. So but to remember the number one cause of thyroid nodules is Hashimoto's so don't think that you can't have more than one thing going on.
So how do you diagnose that Hashimoto's you have to do the full thyroid blood flow file. So full thyroid test is going to include your T3, your T4 and that's going to be three T3, three T4.
It's going to include your TSH it's going to include your TPO antibodies and your thyroid thyroid globular antibodies and it's going to include reverse T3 would be good to have it out there.
And so just make sure that you look at the biggest picture that you possibly can on your thyroid.
These tests your thyroid antibodies sorry these to test your TPO antibodies and your thyroid globular antibodies are going to diagnose Hashimoto's.
So if you have TPO and or thyroid globular antibodies that are elevated you have Hashimoto's if your thyroid is hyperactive and you have either one of these then you have what's called graves disease.
And that's a much more serious thing that you have to take care of in a different way. But Hashimoto's is the number one cause of increased nodules don't think you that you have thyroid cancer that diagnosed that you can't also have Hashimoto's.
So a local functional medicine doctor I know just told me today about two products from biotics research receptor detox.
It does what it sounds like and hormone balance and protect supposed to have the same effect some low dose they'll track some have you heard of these products.
And if so what do you think about them okay so yes I've heard about these near two new products by biotics we actually carry both these products here they are this one is the hormone balance I think what are the other.
And quite honestly when they came up with them they sent me three bottles over one of the to quite honestly I'm not really impressed.
So biotics has some really good products they have really good glandulars I really like their glandular products carried biotics for decades.
If you're looking for about our store understand they just change your policy we can't have any of their products invisible on our store so people have to call in to buy their products right.
Which that's their policy so it is usually I'm not super impressed with this product is okay so it's got calcium be glittering which could be good for hormone balance that's good.
But got cilantro which is a which is a help with heavy metal toxicity deadline which is a help with liver balance and helping with detox pathways.
Lastly which is minor minor player with detoxing things corolla which again cilantro and corolla would in my book would be mild detoxers and milk this for liver issues is really not this is really I as well as what are why they're there this is build as a receptor detox.
This is really not pulling estrogens off the reset you want to really name something receptor detox if you want to say you're you're pulling estrogens off a receptors.
Then you you have to talk about fermented soy so that's the only thing that will dislodge estrogen from estrogen beta receptors so that's the only product that's out there now is that Highland.
I buy one that's the only product that is out there that does that so I was disappointed in their name into this product and thinking this is what it is.
And then this one is another is a good product for for bone balance still just got a balance of supplements that most everybody's already taking these.
And then it's got hammer broccoli which I mean it's it's good to have broccoli sheet extract I mean that's what so far as I am is grape seed extract most people have that and other things boron and and did sing can be good for the brain and the blood brain barrier.
Stingy dental which can be good it's a flavonoid that can decrease inflammation and milk this for the liver to me this is just not a very specific.
Or complete product for hormone balance whatsoever so I was quite honestly I think they're they're all with products I was just so disappointed how they're selling it.
It's just to me I was a super disappointed I just thought we get it we put them on our store I don't recommend them for people on the last page of the genetics test you listed two more suppressor genes and one of them highlighted was rock.
And when we look at your tumor suppressor genes we look at all the tumor suppressor genes in the test that we run in what the test for so you had if I highlighted it you had a lot of rocket genes might not have been the specific rocket genes that your medical doctors looking for that is really dangerous but if you still have a lot of rocket genes defective defects I still want to support that.
So the support for drop of rocket defects is to her so knowing this which I made recommendations so when I look at your genetics I make treatment decisions and make recommendations based upon these things so if I made a recommendation that's what I made it up so.
The oncologist want to be to take a genetic test now they're just going to run like 25 genes or something like that which is just fine what I'm doing they want to do it if your church will cover it that's just funny i see now that last page that curcumid is indicated for three or four by two or suppressor genes that's that's why I recommend curcumid yes.
So then you continues the question you are already taking the premier research labs preventive tumor plus and standard process tumor forte there is some turmeric also in the sun fiber can you get too much turmeric.
Not unless you have food sensitivity to turmeric really you can't get too much to work a lot of studies for cancer and turmeric this is given that even if person doesn't have any genetic defects suggesting maybe wanting to use more turmeric talk about anywhere between two to 10 grams of turmeric that's a whole lot of curcumid so that's why it can be good to get it in bulk and it had just had some.
And some bulk to work that you can even buy at the health store that you can have your smoothie can be really good.
Also you said to use a hot compress over my liver for 13 it been 15 30 15 to 30 minutes a day do you mean with her without cast or oil yes it's exactly what I mean with their without cast or oil and the reason why I say that is that i'm not trying to add more burden to you so yes if you do it with cast or oil that's good.
Cast or oil that's even better but a lot of times if I say do a 15 to 30 minute cast or oil pack over your liver every day some people just won't take it just they just won't do it I I I get it I understand human nature well enough to.
I thought if I add too much people will just not do it so if you have the ability to do cast or oil then do it but if you're like really busy and you're just sat down and you're tired and you just sat down and you're going to watch a show or something like that you have a hot pack city by the chair that you said.
Santa just grab the hot pack and turn the thing on so use the heating pad the U T K far infrared heat pad that's the one we have it.
So just use that don't they got to get up a new class to oil or I can't do it at all okay so don't don't put that burden on so cast or all pack is better with heating pack is better than doctor it at all.
Okay back to these questions is there a blood test that tells or indicates cancer row it again if so what kind of test.
No there isn't a blood test that specifically tells cancers growing there's some things that give us clues so you can do to our suppressor test our tuber marker tests and you can see in the blog if you look at the blog.
Where do you look at the blog right there there's look at the eye click on that little eyeglass and type in to our suppressor tests and you'll get a list of tuber or tuber marker tests you'll get a list of to a marker test that could be beneficial for your cancer but there's that if that doesn't totally indicate that your cancer is growing if your PSA let's say for a male with prostate cancer.
Those from 7 to 11 that doesn't mean it's growing it can you have to look at it against remember not one test is perfect so you got to look at that test and measure it with you know CT scan or MRI or ultrasound you know and look at what you're willing to go through for.
To find that data so you also look at it comparing with subjective tests as well when you stop pharmaceutical medications like I've rants or low shots and such and the cancer still active how long does it take for your body to adjust to the tuber marker tests.
I don't know and I don't think there's any any written data of that i've never seen any studies about that.
Sometimes different so I think the person's referring to you any type of medication can interfere with any blood tests but certainly there are there is data out there that states that chemotherapy like eye breads could interfere with the tuber marker test.
I don't know that there's a time frame so it's really hard I don't know I don't know what to answer that question maybe just get them done you know just like for breast cancer tuber marker set isn't that expensive it's not so hard box and you could get it done maybe in a month every month and see what it looks like if my results for my cheek swab came back saying my cancer is.
Amito acid based is that mean I should never eat red meat again so we never say that your cancer is a amino acid based we might say that we think red meat can drive your cancer so.
If we think that red meat is could be a driver of your cancer we recommend that you don't eat red meat does it mean you could never eat red meat again.
No, that does not mean that so my personally I believe when I tested myself I felt like my mind was was driven by meat so I laid off of meat for some for fish for a long time but now I mean together about having any dishes.
Is that the wisest thing to do well I don't know I pray about it really doing what I think is best so.
If my Dutch test results showing my estrogen and progesterone were both depleted should not having any is that okay yes as long as you're okay with any symptom patterns that might results from that so let's say your cancer is in full revision and let's say you had breast cancer
that was your positive or to positive and your in full revision and your estrogen progesterone are like zero on a Dutch test.
If you're having symptoms because of that which you can have all sorts of symptoms having to roll a progesterone estrogen you're not going to get into that right now could you add a little progesterone or estrogen back to the mix.
You just kind of be really careful you have to it's just like you know that's that's much more of a faster driver than adding a food back so I'd be careful with that.
That's a decision you're not to make if you know if you did not have an estrogen or progesterone or her to positive cancer and your inflammation and your depleted progesterone and estrogen you could maybe add a little estrogen.
A progesterone cream I would never add estrogen but you could add some progesterone cream that's something that you're going to have to talk to your folks your doctor back.
You would put the on a roll up clear for estrogen because dim had didn't say you know others that have to be up by a suit of roll up clear works like dim roll up clear has dim in it so instead of clear dim clear dim has other things that that can.
That can do other things that could possibly have ham too up roll up clear is just a clear meaty that's just has less things in it so that's why I recommend that.
I'm taking fed med dissolved five times a week progesterone cancer and I'm wondering if adding either mectin would enhance the therapy first days through diagnosis so I think we talked about this last week and a big fan of either mectin.
I'm a mectin works really a kind of different pathway that that bed is also it's not like well I'm taking it but it is also I shouldn't take ever mectin.
It's not like that at all really work in a different pathway I think so no I I don't think there's any power or follow and I talked about this last week I don't there's I don't people personally that are taking ever mectin.
On a very regular basis they might not be taking it every day but maybe they're taking it three days a week and they've been doing it since COVID so no ill effects so I don't think there's anything for that I have a 16.4 PSA currently and I'm going to reduce this in the last 10 months I don't I personally I will take it.
I'm using the right for paecreatic cancer but my doctor is saying that aren't even sure it's coming from the paecreases where RGCC test came back unsure but I would trust the RGCC test for where my cancer is.
So it gets back to the biopsy and I can't remember your case whether you're at a biopsy or not but if you had a biopsy sure paecreatic cancer then I could go off of that although I do have a system that paecrease does this be my right program might not be doing anything if it's not paecreatic cancer well can kind of be that you don't have just paecreatic cancer.
I don't think there's any other program in there but yeah I mean you want to be as specific as possible so let's say you have I mean there's really any other cancer that's going to test the size of paecrease so you could have a cyst that is a demon cancerous a cyst on your paecrease and it's not paecreatic cancer whether you're actually running the right for a preventative paecreatic cancer.
But they're saying it's definitely coming from somewhere dealing with the digestive system my doctor is almost sure it's paecrease but not 100%.
If you want said it in a cheek swab and I can give you a secondary program or annual carcinoma which is 95% of the cancers that are other digestive in nature if you want to do that I can do that.
So for sure then you could run like every other night or something.
I would like to try fed medisol as well would love your thoughts on how much you take.
I would if you're going to try fed medisol I was going to try fed medisol that's best way to put it.
I would do one pack a day four days a week so one pack a day comes in individual packs.
We can't sell it on our store sorry we can sell it but we can't have it up on our store.
There's the beta that the FDA came after us because of what we had on the listing.
We could probably put it back on the store as long as we don't say anything about cancer because you know other places have it.
So I think we could actually put it back on our store if we just took off anything about using the cancer or how you would use it.
Just do one pack a day you could mix it in your smoothie.
That's the best way to do it.
The first and do it only four days a week.
The first nodule was biopsy and it was cancer.
This is going back to the thyroid crush I believe.
So thank you.
This one.
A cancerous it was not fed to be trail like.
I have a dominate.
So.
If it is talk if you are talking about this question right here, then.
I would consider getting the next one.
I don't think that there's real much of a danger getting a needle biopsy of a thyroid dog because it's pretty close to the surface.
What are your thoughts on chelation and doing SOT so SOT the therapy SOT.
We've had we talked about that before we've had a couple of patients that have done it.
Their experience wasn't great, but it doesn't mean that you know that's a couple out of maybe a thousand people have done.
I don't know.
But so that's a kid.
I don't know a lot about it.
So chelation.
Yeah, I'm really big into chelation.
We're talking about IV chelation that you really got to go to the course and mirror and go to the.
Seven phases of detox course and make sure you read through that watch those things because if you start doing IV chelation without.
Have a year.
Other six phases of detox open.
You could make yourself sick.
A test it for a tomato XL.
That's a that is a brand by apex.
Curriculum.
A lot of year ago I'm having a hard time fighting a reason for the price.
We have it on our store.
We just can't have it lying on our store.
So just like biotics.
Some companies just don't let us have it live.
And we can look.
You can just call us and get prices for it.
We actually have it downstairs right now.
So.
What are your thoughts on PS 150 possible to the Syrian.
So possible to the Syrian is a great product for brain health and real transmitter balance.
And.
Even help.
It works together with possible collied.
It help with with your cell membranes.
So.
I don't think anybody can go wrong with possible to a Syrian attitude.
It's not really a cancer killer or anything like that.
But it's good for brain health.
Should I be using my grounding pad along with my right.
So maybe we should have some help.
A.
How would you treat Hashimoto's.
Well.
Good thing for you that what's in a week or so we're going to have.
Our so there'll be another course, right?
This spot right here.
Call.
on the videos I want today, product disease and autoimmune disease. So you are going to be
able to read up everything about Hashimoto's and how they treated effectively. Did you receive
my pathology report in my email last week? Any comments for future treatment if I decline chemo
and radiation? Yes, I do believe I did see that. You should probably call it schedule at a time
to talk to me about that. I don't think I got it. Cheekswap can be really simple. So I want to look
up actually. My doctor is saying my cancer is in such early stages and in the end or so we would
say I don't have cancer. My cell markers went down from 3.8 to 3.3. What are your thoughts?
I did RGCC. So yeah, this is back to that pancreas thing. I would say just do another cheek swab
and I'll get you another program. Please put that on the website over there so that we just have
everything covered. We get any other intestinal cancer covering probably right?
I don't know that for people in the past that they weren't sure if they had cancer, they did not want to,
you know, they had a number of people in the past that had lesions on their liver and they refused
to get biopsies. They just didn't want to do it biopsy. So I actually wrote program so many cancers
can metastasize to the liver. So I wrote some mixed cancer programs for them that they could kind of
cover all their bases. They didn't have a lot of time on each cancer on their overnight program.
They felt like it covered their bases and all those people are still alive today. So
I've heard that tuberculosis estrogetic for a couple of different places. I can't be, I don't think
it's a strong estrogetic so it's not something I'd be concerned with. And certainly I have never seen
a raise any rises in estrogen on a duct test of people that are doing fairly high doses of estrogen.
Good questions tonight. Anything else? All right, so
just a reminder, if you want what we call an educational coaching call, just fill out that coaching
call request form on any issues that you might be having and you could pay for it online too
and call for aid and schedule and call and go from there. All right, go please,
that you guys know that I'm great for all of you and I'm sure it's your courage for us as well.
I love you all and we'll see you next week. Bye.